The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
OK.
So we have-- you can show
the answer-- 57%, 1 and 3.
So this is where we were
at the end of last lecture,
so if you didn't get this
written down in your notes,
you want to look at
these definitions.
So here in this, we have
NH3 with its lone pair,
and it is acting
as the Lewis base,
and BF3 is acting
as the Lewis acid.
So a Lewis base donates
its lone pair electrons,
and the acid accepts them.
So what was the
other definition?
We had the Bronsted-Lowry.
Does someone want to tell
me what that definition was?
Can we have a volunteer tell us
the Bronsted-Lowry definition?
Pull out your notes.
There you go.
AUDIENCE: So a Bronsted-Lowry--
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
I'm not sure it's on.
It is on?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Bronsted-Lowry
base is something that
accepts H plus or H3O plus.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yeah.
So the base accepts the
hydrogen ion or the proton,
and the acid donates.
So is this definition
now incompatible,
or are they completely
opposite, or could they
be worked together?
Does anyone have
an opinion on that?
So how many people
think that these
could be consistent
definitions in some way?
OK.
Oh, quite a few people.
One could make that argument.
So if you know now that
you can make the argument,
does someone want
to try to make it?
We have a bag.
All right.
Our mic went away, but
can we get up over there?
So where did our mic runner go?
I should have explained
they were needed twice.
All right.
All right, who said
they might try this?
AUDIENCE: All Bronsted-Lowry
bases are Lewis spaces,
but not all Lewis bases
are Bronsted-Lowry bases
because you can act as a
proxy with no hydrogen ion
if it connects directly.
But if a hydrogen ion
bonds, an example H3O,
to the lone pair of
oxygen, then it's
the same thing as a Lewis base.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: OK.
so that's right.
The Lewis acid-Lewis
base definition
works if you don't
have a hydrogen
ion involved or a
proton involved,
but the other still applies.
So remember that when
you're accepting H plus,
you're taking it
without an electron,
so the base is taking H plus,
so it's donating its electrons
to form the bond.
And the acid, when
it gives up H plus,
it's keeping all
of the electrons.
It's accepting the electrons, so
when the acid gives up H plus,
it's accepting, and when
the base takes H plus,
it's using its electrons.
So the Lewis definitions are
lone-pair or electron-centric
definitions, whereas,
Bronsted-Lowry
is thinking about the proton,
but they both work together.
So that's a good review
of the definitions
we talked about last
time, and now I'll
try to get my mic back on.
All right.
So today we're going to continue
talking about acid base,
and we're going to continue
talking about acid base quite
a bit.
So we have a number more
lectures on acid base.
So we're going to start
today with the relationship
between pKw, pH,
and pOH, we're going
to talk about the strengths
of acids and bases,
and then we're going to
start doing equilibrium
acid-base problems.
And we're going to
do a bunch of those.
And students who are
doing this and learning it
for the first time
are telling me there
is an infinite number of
different kinds of problems.
It's really not true.
There are only five different
types, and today hopefully,
we'll get through two of them.
So first we need to
think about water
because water is a really
important solvent when
we're talking about
acid base equilibrium.
And we mentioned
last time that water
can act as an acid and a base.
Does anyone remember what
that's called, something that
can act as an acid and a base?
AUDIENCE: Amphoteric.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Amphoteric.
So here we can think
about two waters
going to H3O plus and OH.
We could also write
it out instead
of just saying two
waters, one water that's
acting as the acid and another
water is acting as a base.
So the water that's acting as an
acid gives up its hydrogen ion,
or proton to the base.
The base accepts it
forming a conjugate acid,
and this water that lost
H plus becomes OH minus.
So water plus water, H2O plus
H2O, forms an acid and a base.
So we can ask the question,
then how much water
is in a glass of water, or
how much H2O is actually
in this water container
that I have here?
So when I'm asking
that question,
how much H2O in a
container of water
and if I know the delta
G0 of that process,
I'm asking about what
is the relationship
between our products
here, our ionized acid
and our base over here, the
ionized products of water,
compared to water
at equilibrium.
Because this container, the
water, is in equilibrium.
So if I'm asking about
the ratio of products
to react as an equilibrium,
what am I asking about?
Just yell it out.
AUDIENCE: Equilibrium.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: I'm asking
about the equilibrium constant.
Exactly.
I'm asking what is K. What
is the equilibrium constant.
So let's just briefly
review the relationship.
We're given here a
delta G0, and we're
asking about K. What is
the relationship, how
do you calculate K
if you know delta G0?
And we have some equations
that will be given to you.
Sorry.
Not quite yet.
There's going to be a
clicker question coming.
We have some equations here.
So we have delta G0 equals
minus RT natural log
of K, which we can
rearrange to solve for K.
And let's just have a
little reminder of what
these terms are.
So we'll put this up here.
T is temperature,
and we're going
to be talking about
room temperature.
This isn't room temperature now.
And in fact, almost
all acid-based problems
are going to be at
room temperature.
There might be a
few differences,
but we have a lot
at room temperature.
We have a constant,
R, and so 8.314 joules
per Kelvin per mole and delta
G. So we were already told
the value for delta G here.
Now, thinking about this room
temperature, this constant,
and this value for
delta G, do you
expect a large or
small value for K
if you have this delta G0 value?
And that's our clicker question.
All right.
Let's just do 10 more seconds.
Yep.
So K, you would expect to be
a small value less than 1.
And you could think
about that mathematically
from these expressions, or
you could think about it
in terms of the value of for
delta G. So if we solve this
and we put in our value
for delta G0, which
is a positive value--
so the forward direction
of the reaction is
non-spontaneous.
So we put in our positive delta
G0 and our other values here,
and this is, again, joules
per Kelvin per mole.
And we have to make sure that
we convert kilojoules to jewels
and our units will cancel out.
And if we do that, we get this
value for natural log of K
and this value for K of 1.0
times 10 to the minus 14th
at room temperature.
And you will find
that you end up
memorizing this value if you
do enough acid-base problems.
In fact, you might have
it memorized already.
So this is, in
fact, a small value.
And that indicates that
only a small proportion
of water molecules are ionized.
About 1 molecule in every
200 million are ionized,
so it's a very,
very small value.
So there is a lot of
H2O in a glass of water.
So in here it's mostly H2O.
Very few molecules
are ionized in that.
Now, part of the
reason why you're
likely to have this
value of K memorized
is because it has
a special name.
This K is called Kw for water.
So that's easy to remember.
And Kw, the equilibrium
constant for water,
is equal to the hydronium
ion concentration
times the hydroxide
ion concentration.
And since this is an
equilibrium constant,
if you're at constant
temperature at room
temperature, this will
always equal 1.0 times 10
to the minus 14th.
This product is always going
to be this at room temperature.
And that is why it's
going to turn out
to be important
because you're going
to use that information in
solving a lot of problems.
All right.
So if this is an
equilibrium constant,
we want to think again about
expressions for equilibrium
and just make a
note that we did not
include water squared on the
bottom of this expression.
So Kw equals hydronium
ion concentration
times hydroxide
ion concentration.
You don't put it over water.
And the reason for this is
because this is a pretty pure
solvent, and you don't
include pure solvents
in your equilibrium expression.
You also don't include solids.
So we talked about that when we
were talking about solubility.
So you have to remember
that solvents like water
is nearly pure, doesn't go in.
Pure other liquids,
pure other solids
are not included in your
equilibrium expression.
All right.
So we now know about water.
We know about Kw.
Let's do a few more
definitions and then
think about how
all of these terms
are related to each other.
So a definition that
many people already know,
probably if you've taken
any kind of science before,
you're probably
aware that pH equals
minus log of the hydronium
ion concentration of H3O plus.
If you don't know it, it will
be on your equation sheet,
so it doesn't really
matter, but there it is.
And there's also pOH.
pOH equals minus log
of the hydroxide ion
concentration, OH minus.
Now, let's think about
the relationships
of pKw, pH, and pOH.
So relationships.
So I just told you
and maybe you've
already memorized
that Kw is going
to be equal to the
hydronium ion concentration
times the hydroxide
ion concentration,
and that's going to be equal to
1.0 times 10 to the minus 14th
at room temperature.
So now, if we take
this expression
and we take the log
of all of these terms
and multiply by
a negative value,
then we will get
this expression.
So minus the log of Kw is pKw.
And minus log of the hydronium
ion concentration is what?
pH minus log of the hydroxide
AUDIENCE: pOH.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: pOH.
So pKw equals pH plus pOH, and
that is equal to 14.00 at room
temperature.
And this is a very
useful expression,
the fact that pH and
pOH are equal to 14.
If you know one of
these, then the other one
by doing a simple subtraction.
So you will find yourself using
this expression quite often
in the problem sets.
And so I'll say that one,
the problem set that that's
due on Friday has just a
couple of acid-based problems
at the end.
The next problem set will
be 100% acid-base problems,
so there's a lot
to look forward to.
So let's talk about the
strengths of acids and bases.
So if you have a
pH of pure water,
it should be equal to minus
log times 1.0 times 10
to the minus 7, or the pH
equals 7, which is a neutral pH.
So if we have a scale here,
pH minus 1 to pH 14, 7
is a neutral value.
If we're talking about
things that are acidic,
the pH of an acidic
solution is less than 7,
and so this is the
acidic part over here.
And the pH of a basic
solution is greater than 7,
so that is down in this part.
The EPA defines
waste as corrosive
if the pH is lower
than 3, so that
would be corrosive, or higher
than 12.5, also corrosive.
So living creatures like to
be more in the neutral range.
When you get to things that are
very low pH or very high pH,
that is less good.
So let's now check out
a few pH's, and I'd
like to have five TAs come
down to help me with this.
And I'll just show you
what we're going to do.
So we'll have some volunteers.
We have pH paper.
The pH paper has
an indicator on.
You put the paper
in the solution
and then try to see
which thing matches best.
So this is a very quick and
dirty way to estimate pH.
There's pH meters and indicator
dyes that work better,
but we'll have five people
measure five things.
We have ammonia, a cleaner.
We talked about the
importance of cleaning
bathrooms last lecture.
We have soda.
We have vinegar, which is
often used in salad dressings.
Before I came here I just
went to a random sink
and got some MIT
water to measure.
And then this, this is special.
This is a prescription medicine.
So this is a solution
of iron 2 sulfate.
And this is prescribed if
have an iron deficiency.
An iron deficiency is pretty
bad, and a lot of kids
have iron deficiencies.
It's really common in infants.
So my daughter had
an iron deficiency,
and this was her medicine.
In fact, this box is completely
full of this medicine.
So kids cannot swallow
pills very easily.
How many of you actually
cannot swallow a pill?
A lot of adults are
pill challenged.
How many are happy
swallowing pills?
Let's do a more positive thing.
OK.
So swallowing pills is
not everyone's favorite.
When you're a kid,
it's really impossible
to tell someone to put
something in their throat
and go back and
try to get it down.
They choke, spit up, it's awful.
So kids have to take
medicine in solution.
So this medicine is 300
milligrams in 5 milliliters.
It's very concentrated,
so my daughter
had a pretty severe
iron deficiency.
So when she tried taking
it, and I tasted it,
it was horrific beyond belief.
And after she had taken
it a couple of times,
she started to have sores on
her tongue and in her mouth.
And I as a chemist said,
let's measure the pH.
So you will measure the pH
of this prescription medicine
for a four-year-old and tell me
whether the EPA would prove it
or not.
Anyway, so here are the TAs, and
they're going to come around.
Raise your hand if you're
willing to measure a pH.
TAs, just grab a solution.
I should have had you pour
it, but OK, we're doing it.
And we'll go around, and
we'll measure, and tell me
what you find, and I'll
write it on the board.
Yeah, OK.
All right.
So we have pH.
Do we have an answer?
Did we get one?
What do you have?
AUDIENCE: Ammonia.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Ammonia is 12.
So almost corrosive,
but not quite.
You can still have
clean, but if you
want an excuse not to clean,
you're like, sorry, too close.
Too Corrosive Do we
have another one?
AUDIENCE: MIT water is 7.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
MIT water is 7?
AUDIENCE: MIT water is 7.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Awesome.
So often, actually, water
that you get from a tap
is not 7 because often there are
ions that are dissolved in it.
But a little bit around
7, a little bit of ions
never hurt anyone.
We have lots of
ions in our body.
Soda?
AUDIENCE: 3 and 1/2.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Soda at 3 and 1/2.
So soda is definitely getting
into our corrosive range.
AUDIENCE: Vinegar at 2.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: And
we have vinegar at 2.
And that is corrosive.
People often use pure vinegar
to clean out a coffee pot
because it is pretty corrosive.
It really does a good
job of cleaning it.
When you're having
it in salad dressing,
you don't want to
have it pure vinegar.
That would not be good to drink.
And what about medicine?
AUDIENCE: Medicine
has a pH of 2.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: 2.
So we also have in
the corrosive category
the medicine that my
four-year-old daughter
was asked to take.
So when she started getting
these sores in her mouth
from taking her medicine, I
brought some pH paper home
and measured the
pH and discovered
that what she was
taking was corrosive.
So I went to the doctor
and said, can you
prescribe something different.
This medicine is corrosive.
And the doctor looked at
me and it's like the pH,
the pH is like 2 or lower.
And she looked at me, and she's
like, what do you mean pH?
This is why I
spend many lectures
on pH in this class
and acids and bases.
Some of you will be
doctors, and some of you
will not encourage parents to
buy this much corrosive thing
to feed their child when
they're iron deficient.
So this is what
I'm talking about.
And for those of you who
are not going to be doctors,
many of you will
probably have children
with an iron deficiency.
It's super common.
So you will know that
you need to measure
the pH of the solution before
giving it to your child.
So what did I do?
So what I did was I bought
adult pills, same stuff,
iron sulfate, and I
made sure that this
told me the number of
milligrams that were in there.
I looked at what was prescribed.
So I got the pills with the
correct number of milligrams,
and then I crushed them,
and that stuff also
tastes really nasty, but a
little tip for the future,
there is one and only
one that I discovered,
taste that can cover the
taste of iron 2 sulfate,
and that is Nutella.
So don't give your child
corrosive medicine.
Give them crushed
pills in Nutella.
pH is important.
So let's talk about
the strengths of acids.
And you might want to reconsider
huge soda consumption too.
I don't really know,
but that's something
you might want to think about.
Strength of acids.
So here we have some acetic
acid, CH3COOH aqueous,
dissolved in our solvent,
which is liquid water.
And this is an acid,
so it will give up
a hydrogen ion or a proton to
the water, which acts as a base
and forms our hydronium
ions, H3O plus, and also
the conjugate base of the acid.
So it's the acid missing
H plus, CH3C00 minus.
So if we're talking about the
strength of the acid, what
we really want to know
is how much of that acid
forms ions, how
much of it ionizes.
That is going to
determine how strong it
is because the
amount that ionizes
is equal to the amount of
the hydronium ions you get,
and pH equals minus
the concentration
of hydronium ions.
So the pH depends on the
extent to which it ionizes.
And again, we're talking
about at equilibrium,
so we're talking about
a equilibrium constant,
and this one also
gets a fancy name.
In acids and bases,
all the equilibrium
constants get their
own little names,
and this is the acid
ionization constant, Ka.
So it's the equilibrium
constant for an acid, Ka.
So that's at least
very easy to remember.
So now based on what you know
about equilibrium constants,
why don't you tell me
the answer to this?
All right 10 more seconds.
All right.
So this one is wrong.
It's always products over
reactants for an equilibrium
expression.
Water is a solvent
and is nearly pure,
so it should not be there.
This should be in the
expression because it's aqueous.
If it were solid, it wouldn't
be included, but it's aqueous,
so its concentration
is going to change,
so it is in our expression.
See answer to 3 for that one.
Enough information,
and it's not correct.
So we can write the
expression for Ka.
So that's equal to the
products, our hydronium ion
concentration, our conjugate
base over are conjugate acid.
And so we can look at what the
value is for this expression,
and we can look it up.
There's lots and lots of
tables of these in your book.
And it is 1.76 times 10
to the minus 5 or minus 3.
I don't have my glasses,
whatever it says there.
I think it's 5 at room
temperature, which is small.
So when Ka is small, it
means that very little of it
is ionizing.
And so only a small number
of our acetic acid molecules
are donating their proton when
they're dissolved in water.
So that's the definition
of a weak acid.
When it has a very small Ka,
it's not ionizing very much.
Now, in doing these
units, a lot of people
get hung up on the names
of the different acids
and one of the first
steps in solving
a problem is to write the
equilibrium expression out,
but people get
hung up with that.
So don't get hung up with that.
You can use generic expressions
for acids and water.
If you don't want to write out
the whole name of the acid,
you can always just say HA,
aqueous, plus the solvent,
water, goes to hydronium
ions plus A minus,
the conjugate of the weak acid.
So this is an acid in water,
and the acid is HA here.
And an acid expression should
be forming hydronium ions.
If it's acidic, you
should have acidic pH,
and so you need to have
some H3O plus around.
You can also write
this expression
as BH plus plus water.
BH plus can give up the H plus
and become B and also generate
hydronium ions.
So here are the acid is BHA.
And often when you're looking
at these kinds of problems,
a weak acid will be
HA, but sometimes you
have a problem involving the
conjugate acid of a weak base,
and that's often
expressed as BH plus.
So both of these expressions
are valid for an acid in water.
So now let's think about strong
acids versus weaker acids,
and here's our
definition in this class.
A strong acid has a Ka greater
than 1, a lot of strong acids
have a Ka really, really,
really greater than 1,
and the acid ionizes
almost completely.
So if you say it's a
strong acid in water,
whatever concentration
of that acid you put in
is going to be equal to the
concentration of hydronium
ions.
It basically goes straight.
You form lots and lots and lots
of products at equilibrium.
A weak acid has a
Ka of less than 1,
and a weak acid does not
for many ionized species
in solution.
Not very much H3O
plus is formed.
So what about pKa?
pKa's are really important in
organic chemistry, in biology,
in a lot of areas.
And every year the organic
chemistry faculty in 512
talk about pKa's in organic,
and the students there say, no,
we never learned about that.
They're like, you took
freshman chem, right?
It's like a GIR or
you pass the test.
You should know about
pKa's, and they're like, no.
So they contact me, and I'm like
they did not take 5.111 if they
do not know what a pKa is.
There are other courses that
sometimes people decide to take
that are not 5.111, but in
5.111, you know about pKa's.
So what I want you to
do is later in life
when you're in a class
and pKa's come up
and everyone else in the
class is like, I don't know.
You're like I took 5.111.
I can answer that.
That makes me very happy.
So pKa's.
so pKa is minus
the log of the Ka.
That's easy to remember.
We already talked about
the relationship of Ka
with strong acids or weak acids.
The lower the value
of the Ka the higher
the value of the pKa.
That's just out of
that expression.
So the higher the pKa
means what about the acid?
Think about what you know about
Ka to answer this question.
All right.
10 more seconds.
So that is correct.
So we have a weaker acid.
So if we have a
low Ka, that means
that it is a weak acid, and
then the higher value of Ka.
So the higher the
Ka, that's going
to mean the lower the value
or the weaker of the acid.
So just remember the
relationship from the equation,
and think about it, and you
can think about the value
of Ka, products over reactants.
You might have a
lot of products.
That means a lot of
ionization and a stronger acid
and fewer products,
that means it's weaker.
So let's look at some
tables, and I just
put the values that are with
the arrows in your notes.
I didn't put the entire table.
The tables are in the book, and
this is page one of the table,
so there's a lot of values here.
So this has the acid.
It tells you what the HA
term is, what the A minus,
so what the weak acid is,
what the conjugate base is.
It gives you the Ka and the pKa.
And so you can see
the relationship
between Ka and pKa.
So up here, HI is at
the top of this table.
So that probably means it's
the strongest or the weakest.
Which do you think?
Is this the strongest
or the weakest?
You just yell it out.
AUDIENCE: Strongest.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
It is the strongest.
Right.
So it has Ka value that is much,
much, much, much, much, much,
much, much, much, much,
much greater than 1.
And it has a very, very, very
negative tiny, tiny pKa value.
So this is a super strong acid.
In fact, do not use that.
There's no reason really you
would ever want to be using it.
It is not a good
thing to play with.
All right.
So HCl is used more
often in pH-ing things.
Is this a strong or weak acid?
AUDIENCE: Strong.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
It's also strong.
It's K or Ka is
also greater than 1,
but not as strong as this.
We have 10 to the seventh,
and that one, gosh,
I should bring my
glasses, 10 to the 11th.
That's super strong.
That's still pretty strong.
All right.
So let's look down here now.
Tell me, is this a
strong or weak acid?
AUDIENCE: Weak.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
That is weak acid.
The Ka is less than 1 here,
and I think that's a minus 2.
And the pKa value, now we're
out of the negative number,
so it's on the bigger side.
And down here, is
this strong or weak?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Also weak.
And it's even weaker
than this one.
It's like 10 to the minus
4, and pKa value is 3.75.
So you see you can
look at the Ka values
and think about whether
it's a strong or weak acid.
You can also look
at the pKa values.
This is really, really
small negative value.
This is a bigger
value down here.
And this is not been
the weakest acid.
There's a whole other page of
tables for acids, lots and lots
of acids.
Less bases.
There are a few, and you will
see this space quite often,
NH3.
So we have a base in water.
The base accepts a hydrogen
ion or proton from the water,
forming NH4 plus.
And then after water
loses its hydrogen ion,
it forms OH minus.
So the equilibrium
expression or the K
for this base in water problem
is called the base ionization
constant, or Kb.
And we can write
that expression here.
We have the ammonium
ion concentration
times the hydroxide
over the concentration
of ammonia.
Again, water is not
in the expression.
It stays pretty much pure
throughout this entire thing.
It's the solvent.
And so this is our
expression for Kb.
And if you're writing
an expression for Kb,
you should always make
sure, check yourself
that you're putting hydroxide
ion concentration in there.
If it is a base in water, it
should be forming hydroxide ion
concentration.
If you start writing a Kb
and you have hydronium ion
concentration in there, you
want to stop and rethink
what you're doing.
So in this case, we
also have a weak base.
1.8 times 10 to the minus
5 is a small number for Kb.
It's a small equilibrium
number, so that means
you're not a lot of products.
Not a lot ionized when you
put this weak base in water.
So only a tiny
amount of NH3 ionizes
to NH4 plus and OH in
solution, so this is what
they call moderately weak base.
So as we saw before, you
can have generic expressions
for a base in water.
We can write B aqueous
plus water goes to BH plus.
The base accepts a
hydrogen ion or proton,
and the water loses
one forming OH minus.
We can also write
the expression that
often exists from the
conjugate of a weak acid,
and this is a weak base.
So A minus plus water goes
to HA plus hydroxide ion
concentration.
So either of these are
generic expressions
that you can write
for a base in water.
So in terms of the
definitions, it's the same.
You would say a strong base
is something that ionizes
almost completely to give OH.
There aren't a lot of
examples of strong bases.
Most of the ones you'll
see in your class
are things like
sodium hydroxide.
Yes, that is hydroxide.
That's a strong base, and
if you put it in water,
you should definitely
form a lot of hydroxide.
So they're not a whole
lot of examples there.
So they're not all those tables.
It's not like the acids.
But there are some terms
that you still need to know.
So pKb equals minus
log of the Kb.
And again, the larger the value
for Kb, the stronger the base.
Again, it tells you you have
a lot that have ionized.
And because of this relationship
of this equation, the larger
the pKb the weaker the base.
Because if you have
a big number here,
you're going to have
a small number there.
So now, let's talk
about conjugate acids
and their bases.
This is super
important for buffers
that, hopefully, we'll
get to in class on Friday.
So the stronger the acid, the
weaker its conjugate base.
The stronger the base, the
weaker its conjugate acid.
And here we have HCl,
which we determined
was a strong acid a little while
ago, giving up its hydrogen
ion to water, forming hydronium
ion concentration and Cl minus.
Cl minus is not a very
good conjugate base.
It's not a good base.
So if we look at this table
when we have a strong acid,
its conjugate it is going
to be ineffective as a base.
You're basically not pushing
that equilibrium back
at all, the other direction.
It's completely ionized,
and it stays that way.
But if you have a
moderately weak acid,
you're going to have a very
weak base, a very weak acid,
you'll have a moderately weak
conjugate base, a strong base
and you'll have something
that's ineffective as an acid.
So they are inversely
related to each other.
So let's think about
why this would be true.
And this relationship holds
Ka times Kb equals Kw.
And we know that Kw is
1.0 times 10 to the minus
14th at room temperature.
And if we put logs and then
minus logs by everything,
we can derive this expression,
which is the pKa plus the pKb
equals the pKw equals 14.00.
So you can't have an acid
and its conjugate base
both be strong.
You can't have a base in its
conjugate acid both be strong.
The pK's need to add up to 14.
So if you have something
that's a good acid,
then its conjugate base is not
going to be particularly good.
The pKa and the pKb
must add up to 14.
If you have something
that's a good base,
its conjugate acid is not
going to be that good.
So these are connected
to each other.
So we can think about,
then, the strong acids
and the strong bases again.
So we talk about
equilibrium, but really this
is pushing the equilibrium
pretty much to completion.
If it's a strong acid in
water, however much strong acid
you put in is how much hydronium
ion concentration you get out.
A strong base is
going to give you
that amount of hydroxide
ion concentration.
Strong acids and bases push
the equilibrium pretty much
completely toward ionization.
We have these numbers of 10 to
the 11th, 10 to the seventh.
These are hugely over here.
We're forming almost
ionizing completely.
Now, for weak acids and
bases, it's very different.
Here the equilibrium you
are going back and forth.
You have this
dynamic equilibrium.
The acid in water is forming
hydronium ions and an A minus,
but a minus is also a
somewhat good, weak base
pushing the equilibrium
back the other way.
So in this case, we have a back
and forth between the forward
and the reverse.
So if you have very
weak, you have moderate,
you have moderate,
you have very weak,
and this is what's important
for forming buffers,
and buffers are
really important.
Let's see if we can get to
one of these types of problems
because they're five we
need to get to in this unit.
And there are only five.
And people will say salt
and water is another,
but salt and water
just breaks down
into weak acid and weak bases.
So everyone can learn how to
do five types of problems,
so this is very doable.
All right.
So let's just look at
equilibrium of weak acids
and we'll save weak
bases for last time.
So a weak acid is vitamin C, and
I brought some vitamin C here.
I tried to do a demo once and
discovered that vitamin C,
it's really coated
well, so it does not
dissolve until it hits
the acid of your stomach,
so I could not dissolve it.
So I'll just hold
this up right here.
But if we had a 500
milligram tablet, which
I think is what this is and
if I had 100 mils of water
and if this wasn't
coated so there's
no way you can dissolve it,
then I could calculate the pH.
So how am I going to do this?
I'm given the Ka, I'm told
the number of milligrams,
and I'm told the
volume of water.
So the first thing you want
to do is calculate molarity.
So you want convert grams
to moles or milligrams
to grams to moles.
And then you want to use your
volume, and you have 100 mils,
but we're going to do molarity.
So we want to convert
milliliters to liters.
And we can calculate 0.0284
molar moles per liter.
Then we can write our
expression, and if you want to,
you can just write
HA here and A minus.
You don't have to write
out the whole thing
if you don't want to.
All right.
So here is the expression again.
Now, just as we saw with
chemical equilibrium,
we can write this table talking
about the initial molarity.
So we have a weak acid we have
no hydronium ion concentration.
We have no weak
conjugate base over here,
so the change then is going to
be the constant, the molarity
that we had, and
these are change
in molarities, so don't put
moles or other things here,
molarity here, minus x, that's
what you have in equilibrium,
plus x plus x.
So we can write our
expression now for Ka.
We're given the
value Ka, and we know
how to write an expression.
We have our hydronium
ion concentration,
our conjugate base over here
over our conjugate acid.
This is equal to x
squared 0.0284 minus x.
Now, if you want to
with these problems,
you can make an
assumption that x
is going to be small
and then not have
to use the quadratic
equation, but you do
need to check your assumption.
But I'll show you how to
do it with an assumption,
so we're going to assume x is
small, and this value, the x,
will drop out.
So we can rewrite
this expression
as x squared over just the
concentration we started with.
And then we can solve for x.
And x, in that case, is
point 0.00151, but really
two significant figures.
Our Ka is just 2.
Now, we can check
the assumption.
And we're going to
check the assumption
that this is, in fact, small.
And if it's less than
5%, then we can use that.
So here this is the
x we calculated.
Here is the amount
times 100% gives us
5.3%, which is more than 5.
5 is the magic number
for the course,
and so then we have to use
the quadratic equation.
Now, a lot of you
probably have calculators
that can work with
quadratic equation,
so you don't really
care, but if you
want to check the assumption,
you can, and sometimes
we'll need to check it.
So this value,
this percent here,
is sometimes called
percent ionization
because it's x over the
amount you started with.
It's the percent that ionized
or percent deprotonated.
If this is an acid,
it's the amount
of hydronium, the
amount that deprotonated
over what you started with.
So sometimes you're asked to
do this even if you're not
checking any assumptions.
All right.
So we got to end with
if a quicker question.
We get here this is really
two significant figures.
So why don't you tell me
how many significant figures
are in your answer for pH.
All right.
10 more seconds.
So let's take a look
at the answer here.
So there's the answer.
So this had two
significant figures,
which means you get
two significant figures
after the decimal point.
So maybe we'll have one
of these in the clicker
competition on Friday, and we'll
do our weak bases next time.
So again, we've been
studying acid base.
And there are only five types
of acid-base problems, weak acid
in water, which we already did,
check, weak basin water, which
we're going to do right
now, and as soon as we're
done doing week
base in water, I'm
going to explain to you
how salt and water are just
weak acid in water or weak
base in water problems.
So you already know how to do
them as soon as they teach you
about weak bases.
And then we're going to
move on and do buffers.
And then next week
we're going to do
strong acids and strong bases,
and then you'll have all five.
You already have enough
that after today's lecture,
you can do, I think,
all the problems
set 7 except for the
last two questions,
I believe, or at least a large
fraction of problem set 7.
I will warn you that acid-base
problems take a lot of writing
and a lot of time to work.
One problem often has
five or six parts to it,
and they're all time-consuming
part pretty much.
So don't leave problem
set 7 to the last minute.
That would be a mistake on
this particular problem set.
Weak bases.
Acid-base type problem 2.
So in this example, we have
ammonia, NH3, in water,
and we measured the
pH of some solutions
before and saw they were basic.
We had a pH of, I
think, 12 last time.
And so this conjugate base
goes to a conjugate acid.
So the base accepts a hydrogen
ion or proton from water,
becomes NH4 plus,
and the water that
lost its hydrogen
ion becomes OH minus,
and that is a base
in water problem
because you're forming
hydroxide ions.
For a base in water, you're
talking about the equilibrium
constant for that base in
water, which has a special name
KB, B for base.
And it's important to
remember the A's and B's
on the equilibrium constant
because it's always
checking your work.
Is this a base in water problem.
People sometimes try to apply
Ka's when they should be doing
Kb's.
So pay attention to basin water.
We're thinking about Kb.
So here if we're going to
calculate the pH of a solution,
we have molarity of 0.15,
and room temperature,
pretty much everything
is at room temperature.
So whenever you're
asked to calculate
the pH of a weak
base in water, you
want to think about
at equilibrium, what's
the condition now, what will
be the condition, what's
the change, and what will be
the condition at equilibrium.
And so you can make this table.
You can write out
the expression.
Again, you can
forget about water.
Water is our solvent.
It's not going to be showing up.
And then put in our
initial molarity, 0.15.
And we put zeros in
the other categories.
And why don't you try the rest?
Is it slowing down?
SAM: [INAUDIBLE] answers
are really quick.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: All right.
Let's just do 10 more seconds.
Yup.
Excellent.
Sam told me everyone
responded really quickly.
So that is, in fact,
what you're going to do.
We'll put that up here as well.
So we lose some of this minus x.
So at equilibrium, we
have point 1.5 minus x.
And we get plus x
here and plus x there.
Now, we can write our Kb for
our base in water, its products,
the conjugate acid, NH4
plus, times the concentration
of hydroxide ions over NH3.
Again, water is the solvent.
It's not in the equation.
And then we can write
it out-- this is x.
That's x, so we have x squared.
And then the change in the
amount of the weak base,
when it's in water,
is 0.15 minus x.
So at this point, you can either
use the quadratic equation,
or you can make an
assumption that x is going
to be small compared to 0.5.
We don't want to make
the assumption up here.
We want to get to this point
before we try the assumption,
and you always need to
check your assumptions
to make sure they are correct.
But if we use the assumption
here just to simplify the math.
And so the assumption
is that this x is small,
so we can drop
that x minus x out,
and then we can calculate
that x is 0.00164.
And then we can
check the assumption,
and that is another
clicker question.
All right.
10 more seconds.
It is number 1.
So here you're checking
the assumption and the way
that you check the assumption
is that you put x that you've
calculated by simplifying
it, divide it by the number
that you're asking is it
smaller than, and then times 100
because our rule is 5%.
So if this value is greater
than 5% of this value,
you need to use the quadratic.
If it's less than 5%,
then you can go ahead
and use your assumption.
And so this is the assumption
we're talking about,
that this number is under 5%.
And for weak acids and bases,
it very often is less than 5%
because they're weak, so
there's not a lot of ionization.
And this is often referred to as
percentage ionization as well.
All right.
So our checking
assumption, again,
that x 0.00164 divided
by 0.15 times 100% is 1%,
1.1, that's less than 5,
so the assumption is OK.
And then we can calculate
pOH because this
is a weak base in water,
so the x that we calculated
is the amount of
hydroxide ion in solution.
So we calculate pOH,
and we get 2.79.
And that's two
significant figures,
everything we had
after the decimal
because everything that we had
was two significant figures.
And so this is two
significant figures,
two significant figures
after the decimal point.
And then you need
to calculate pH
because the problem
asked for pH.
So this is, again,
at room temperature.
So we can use 14
minus 2.79 is 11.21.
That's our pH.
And don't make the
mistake of stopping here
forgetting that x is hydroxide
instead of hydronium ion
and tell me that the pH of my
weak base in solution is pH 2.
So one of the things that's
really good about this unit
is that there are some
good checks that you've got
the right answer at the end.
If you're talking about
a base in solution,
you should have a
pH above what value?
AUDIENCE: 7.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: About 7.
So it should be on the
basic side of neutral.
pH 7 is neutral, so
it should be above 7.
And so if this was
your answer for pH,
that wouldn't make
a lot of sense.
So always check at the end.
And it's fine if you get to
an exam and you get to the end
and you did something
wrong and you
realize that your answer doesn't
make any sense, if you write,
this answer doesn't
make any sense,
but I don't have time to
figure out what I gave wrong,
you will get points for
recognizing that that is not
a valid answer.
Because it's a weak
acid problem and you
have a basic pH or vice versa.
So keep that in mind.
There's lots of partial credit.
Grading acid-base
problems on exams
is a whole new fun adventure
that the TAs have no idea what
is going to be happening.
But I'll be right with you
there for 10 hours of grading,
and we'll have a good time.
Write neatly, please.